well some 20 years ago or so but on the
air about 25 years so it might even be
25 years ago
I had gone through the process of
coaching and counseling people getting
out of debt on a one-on-one basis I was
just starting on the radio quarter of a
century ago and even though I'm a
big-time math nerd I had discovered that
debt what Larry Burkett used to say is
not the problem it is the symptom of the
problem the problem is the behaviors you
disorganized you buy crap you can't
afford with money you don't have to
impress people you don't really like
debt is not the problem it's the symptom
of the person in your mirror person in
my mirror if I can get the guy in my
mirror to behave he can be skinny and
rich but he's got issues and that's what
we've learned a long long time ago and
so I quit using only math to do personal
finance because personal finance is more
about behavior than it is about math
math is not the problem an example is
you know what you pay in commissions on
your investments is not the problem the
fact that you put nothing into your
investments is the problem as a matter
of fact there's a key piece of research
from the investment world that shows
that 74% of the reason people have
successful retirement plans is what's
called savings rate meaning they
actually put money into savings it's not
the rate of return and it's not the
expenses and it's not the type of
investment and it's not how complicated
it is
it's just that they put money in there I
met with an NFL player stop by my office
meeting with one of my guys about three
or four weeks ago he stopped by here and
he had a million six in cash in the bank
making 1% and he was ashamed I said why
are you ashamed well it doesn't feel
very
sophisticated will dude it's a whole
heck of a lot more sophisticated than
those people that don't have a million
six in the bank because they started
doing a bunch of quote sophisticated
stuff and they were more concerned about
their sophistication than they were
actually doing it doing it is what
matters this all this theory financial
people are the world's worst about a
bunch of dadgum theories it's this
theory it's that theory and they think
this stuff is all somehow done in a
vacuum it's not done in a vacuum it's
done in the middle of the transmission
going out and your daughter needing a
prom dress life is messy baby and it's
called personal finance so we started
teaching people to get away the best way
to get out of debt is to get some quick
wins the best way you get a quick win is
you list your debts not highest interest
rate to smallest to attack them you list
them smallest debt to largest because
when you pay off the little one you have
an oh boy moment and then you pay off
another one you have a oh ya moment and
then you have a yeah baby moment as you
go along you get more excited and you
get more intense and you get more
focused and we call that the debt
snowball 25 years ago now there are
entire websites devoted to how stupid
Dave Ramsey is because he can't do math
but I've gotten more people out of debt
than any 73 of those idiots put together
so now now we know it's okay though
because it has just come out the Harvard
Business Review our research suggests
that people are more motivated to get
out of debt not only by concentrating on
one account but also by beginning with
the smallest 25 years and five million
people been through Financial Peace
University 13 million people listen to
this show 10 and a half million people
have bought our books and Harvard
Business Review has discovered that our
research suggests that people are more
motivated to get out of debt not only by
concentrating on one account but by also
beginning with the smallest we found
that consumers have concentrated their
repayment on one of their several
accounts paid down more of the credit
card debt than those who dispersed the
repayments equally across multiple
accounts with evidence that repayment
strategy influences debt
we conducted three experiments to
investigate the psychological mechanisms
underlying these results see I knew it's
just but I you know I just I I graduated
from college at a state school so
University of Tennessee is just doesn't
make you smart enough to be able do this
so I'm so glad Harvard Business Review
come along and figure this crap out for
us because we just didn't know it
already participants who had been
assigned to a more concentrated strategy
paying off one or just a few accounts at
a time did indeed perceive greater
progress toward their goal of getting
out of debt which turn in turn enhanced
their motivation to succeed see I just
couldn't say it that beautifully I just
said people get fired up when they pay
off debt and they keep going that's what
I said I'm from Tennessee though
focusing on paying down the account with
a Louis smallest balance tends to have
the most powerful effect on people's
sense of progress you know why because
they have guys are freaking geniuses up
right are vernman so glad you guys
figured this out because none of the
rest of us knew what was going on and
and I'll just the next time one of these
people that you know it's 28 years old
lives and their mother's basement writes
a blog about how stupid Dave Ramsey is
I'll just send them the Harvard Business
Review and I'm sure that'll settle the
debate personal finance folks is 80%
behavior it's only 20% head knowledge
you want to know what's wrong with your
money you you're the problem
that's the bad news great news is you're
the solution and you don't live in
Russia you live in the United States of
America where you get to choose to
change right now you ready change ready
set go tada
you're different just because you
decided to be it's magical it's amazing
you just get to decide
I was stupid yesterday today I'm not
stupid anymore you can just decide not
to do stupid anymore all my parents were
stupid I don't care about your parents
I'm talking about you you know you get
to decide and you don't have to have a
master's degree in finance to figure
this crap out and you don't even have to
have tended I have attended Harvard
Business School you just have to live on
less than you make a concept Congress
can't grasp and you can decide to do
that ready set go
you're now cooking at home and you're
needy not eating out ready set go
you start buying term insurance into the
whole life and getting ripped off ready
set go
you don't fleece your car's you buy used
cars and you pay cash ready set go
you go to every dollar calm and you get
on a budget and you agree on your
spending with your spouse ready set go
you save an emergency fund ready set go
you can do this and regular people do it
every day long before Harvard Business
Review had a clue we were all out here
as a matter of fact they still don't
know we're here
don't tell them this is the Dave Ramsey
show